The four kinds of transportation: planes,
trains, boats and automobiles.
But one preeminent entrepreneur wants to create
a new, fifth transport method.
Hey people Trace here for Dnews with the lowdown
on a new technology announcements, hyper loop.
Elon Musk thought of it.
He is the billionaire creator of Pay Pal,
CEO of Tesla Motors, and SpaceX.
So when he talks,the tech world stop tweeting
for about half a second to listen.
The specifics on how hyper loop would work
are still under wraps, further details are
coming out next month.
But extrapolating for what Musk said in June,
it will be able to go from San Francisco to
Los Angeles in 30 minutes, and New York to
LA in 45 minutes.
The plan, we think, is to create a Jetson-like
bank-style vacuum tube transport system.
The transport can't crash and it floats like
an air hockey puck.
It's pretty fantastical.
The project will cost $6 billion dollars,
relatively cheap for an ultra-fast transport
system and will ideally be solar-powered.
Though, there's not an announced plan yet.
Experts have already weighed in and people
are pretty excited.
As long as we're waiting, I gathered a couple
of other things that we should make some plans
for.
Firstly, a space elevator.
I mean rocket's are cool and all.
They make a lot of noise and they create some
fantastic pictures.
But there's a better way to get into space,
if we can figure it out.
A space elevator is simply a twenty-two thousand
mile cable with the nine hundred ton elevator
crawling up and down it.
Real simple.
Some plans call for a platform floating in
the Pacific around the equator and the other
platform is in space.
With a price of about ten thousand dollars
per pound per rocket, a space elevator would
reduce that to about a hundred to four hundred
dollars per pound, theoretically.
There is one tiny problem.
We just are not smart enough to make it.
The plan was to use carbon nanotubes, but
we can only make them a few inches long at
a time at the moment and they're looking like
they may not even handle the tensions involved.
So we're stuck on the ground, for now.
By the way water travel could also be revolutionized.
This is a technology call super cavitation.
Scientific American calls at warp speed for
underwater ships.
Cavitation happens around the edges of propellers.
It has to do with the physical behaviour of
fluids.
Swiss mathematician Daniel Bernoulli discovered
that fluid velocity is directly related to
pressure and density.
So when you carve through the water in the
right way, like a propeller for example, you
force it to change state to conserve energy.
If we did this rapidly and constantly across
the whole surface, we could it cause super
cavitation, which would theoretically form
a bubble of vaporized water around an entire
vessel.
That bubble could reduce the friction and
increase potential underwater speed by sixty
to seventy percent.
That is alot.
Unfortunately, like the space elevator and
theoretical hyper loop, we have not quite
figured out this one either.
But the future of transportation looks bright,
and fast, and bubbly.
Tell us which of these technologies you think
we should be putting all the money into or
perhaps another one of your favorites.
And make sure you come find us on Facebook,
Twitter, and Google+ so you do not miss the
special behind-the-scenes stuff.
That's right.
Thanks a lot for watching Dnews everybody.
I'm Trace, see later.